what oh this game just keeps getting
weirder and
weirder
wow Hey look it's me and my boy dead
mouse and we're
just
yay what was that
noise
hello and welcome welcome back it's
random encounter the weekly live
streaming show every Wednesday 11:
specific right here on
gamespot.com also on Twitch but mostly
on gamespot.com hope you're enjoying the
new chat E3 is over folks it's done all
this new game's [__] we don't have
to worry about it anymore we can start
concentrating on what matters Ms what
matters more than the latest update to
everyone's favorite goatsy emulator Goat
Simulator there it is get out of
way goats M goats goat
simulator I haven't played this since
vanilla I I was back I was I was logging
on to the goat simulator servers back on
vanilla Goat Simulator but uh now
they've added a bunch of new stuff so
let's Jump Right
In
there we go key bindings that's not new
workshop this is kind of what I want to
what I want to see more than anything
else I might do this
later have a proper browse but the uh
Steam Workshop stuff has
been well they've already got Nigel
Thornbury so you know it's pretty good
we're going to get into that later H
there's a bunch of mechanical stuff has
been added to the actual game itself so
let's uh let's have a look at
that go City Bay I haven't played yet
these are ones I downloaded
earlier uh Italian dinosaur goat these
are all ones I bought as
well cute
goat I'm got to go with vanilla goat let
go into goat City Bay and see what
happens yeah so they added a bunch of
stuff like uh apparently you can wall
ride now and uh and also you can manual
but I'm not really sure how that works
Eric Taylor brought me pizza you're the
best person in the whole world look at
this look at this you think Goat
Simulator could be any better I get
brought one piece you get one piece you
brought look at the two pieces Eric
brought say hi to
people my favorite you're my favorite
you bring the pizza look at the two
pizzas you're like you bring and then
I'll pick which one I'm obious going to
pick this one cuz I'm not an [__]
so yeah good luck thank you Eric you're
the
best oh my [__] goat got hit by a car
while I was eating pizza well pain now
all right this's go City Bay look at
this lady
H come here come back here that's
more a
licker yeah come with me come with me to
Goat City
Bay yep it's still a goat simulator come
here my friend come here my friend Derek
oh he already managed to kill himself
yep there right i' be I'll be freaked
out too
bro
yeah uh yeah so one of the things
they've
added except for licking ladies actually
that was in the previous movie is Titan
4 baby yeah oh maybe here we go [__]
wall running that's what's
up every video game has wall running now
so Goat Simulator clearly has to have it
as well [__]
yeah apparently there's also
uh
manuals should work like forward
backwards right if this was Tony hog I
go h
no hey what's going
on oh this town looks a lot like the old
town then oh
hello it's got a fair ground let's go to
the fair
ground yeah so
can I swim now can I swim can swim look
at my sweet goat swimming
ability wow that's some real sick
swimming Unreal Engine how do I get out
of here use this
pipe sweet in the
sewers repulsion power
gained oh they're going to not like me
now because I smell like like human [__]
what the hell faking Ninja Turtles get
away from
me lick you
donatell they just straight up have the
ninja turtles in here all right air
headb Michael Bay
Turtle my M specifically the Michael Bay
Turtles get away from
me
Christ
dancing lick Michael Bay
Turtle
no I'm going to I'm going to take you
with me come with me what's
this work
whoa what the hell is that
thing look at
this at this goat Monument thing I want
to lick that give me that no not the
stop licking the bre a stupid
Turtle there you
go picked it up I guess there are
collectibles in this
now God I love go simulator so much all
right out of here out of
here don't
go away from
me I have to come do I have to go out
the way I came in I take you with me
come here
he come
here come with
me I want to show you the wonders of the
outside world and introduce you to my
friend April
O'Neal where's he gone where's he
gone my Tong what's up with my tongue
there is that him no all right guess we
can't get them out of
here oh that guy kill
himself it's dark better lick his corpse
M so much Wonder this is just like the
first time I play Goat Simulator who
knows what could happen
next a level of
Wonder it's my goaty duty to make sure I
explore as much of this world as
possible where's the fairgr over there
so
Soo maybe that's a joke in Swedish
FP
hey what's going
on hey what's
up so fun it is so fun it
is murder people come
here I'm going to have to go in this one
first going to skip the line skip the
line away from me it's my
go
yeah
all right man this deeply
confusing there you
go that's what's up yep that's what's up
yep oh god
oh able to do some really good Dives
when he's unconscious all
right need to make sure I it when it's
getting high oh hi that's
it yep nailed
it the fairr is so much
fun look
Mommy dick Jerry
gun [__] get away get away my theme
park I don't think they used to talk as
much as they do in this one that's cool
fcy castle I love the B castle get out
away
go the only way to enter a bansy castle
is through a different bouncing
apparatus
ah tramampoline
trampoline here we
go that's what's up that's what's up
that's yep nailed it
I'm going to jump in this
uh going to jump in this um roller
coaster when it passes
by just lick it here I'll just stay
here Lick Lick
no jump from bansy Castle to bansy
Castle come
on
oh oh I don't think this is up the
code there we
go yeah that's not I don't think this is
really wall running is there a real
thing on this oh there is look at it
here we
go yeah [__] I tried to lick it I tried
to lick it come on go back go back go
back go back go back go back go
back you can do it you can do it land
there land there yeah nailed it
on I can do
it can't go any higher I'm going to have
to time this
perfectly
[__] ah going for a
swim maybe there's another way of
getting in there hey what's going on you
guys doing
drugs there [__]
drugs
who Sun baites out
a fair ground
honestly thatd freak out
too what's in here what ride is this
[__] bull
Great gold Rider whoa get get out the
[__] what what I am not okay with this
get off of me lady get off of
me oh God I think she might be
dead yeah oh Jesus Christ this is just
the
worst hold on
lady enjoying your time at the
fairr are you enjoying your time at the
fair
Grand
no
yes sometimes my mom asks me what I do
for a
Liv just going to send her this in
future go let's go to Ben Castle
together
lady flip jumps s jumps yeah now you're
goting now yep
stupidly
wide yep it's definitely killing
her right where's go next lady there
must be something else to do
here get all these sick achievements oh
man I got this one yeah what you looking
at me for I just got I got a L's riding
on my
back so weird about
it let's go in here
honey let's enjoy the view well you can
enjoy the view I can't really see
it
the world's slowest Ferris wheel I guess
that's a good thing you get more money
for your
ride I just want one of them to fall
down so I can jump on top of it come on
keep
coming
go how's the view now
honey you pregnant or just is your spine
broken
again it's
awful aren't you so glad we moved to
this town instead of that Old Goat
Simulator time we were
in
yep me
too
really hoping I might kill her but well
you know I kill her she's already dead
clearly
but all right let's go over a look
around town see what else is going
on blw up cars
confirmed
yep what's going on what's going on
mister cus Pawn
shop this person seems to be freaked out
by everything that's happening I don't
blame you this is really
terrifying seem to be impervious to
everything now that I've got this lady
lying on my back which is pretty
rad go for a walk in the forest
honey nature that's not terrifying at
all until we came
here a sweet low
friction we show you had a skateboard
oops longboarders
uh look it's your twin it's your twin
come
here let's all skateboard together come
here come here come here come here no
come here come here I want to lick you
come
here I want to lick
you
have mercy do
it
skateboarding
jump
and 10 points all right honey go
somewhere
else
ooh can I jump across those buildings
hey what's up drunk
teenager back to
school all right I need to get up
here my sweet skateboarding skill is to
get up here come
on
right jump come on
go
on not over here anything of
those
champoline here we
go you can make it you can make it a you
son of a
[__] all right let's try that again
might be an Easter EG over there worth
hunting down come on
honey
[__] sorry it wasn't
looking nailed it no maybe not come on a
God damn
it just take the stairs how about
that
yeah God Dam
it all right going to come back to
this I want to show my my lady more of
the
Town let's do
it what else is
here
River jerks and track
suits over
there oh Arrow I don't
even oo Cafe hello I have a coffee and
my lady have
a cookie oh her face is stuck in the
wall that's that's pretty
awful
I'd love to know like the meaning behind
some of this stuff I wonder if they just
like made cafes that were in their
Hometown this frame rate sure why
not how you enjoying your leisurely walk
my
lady gets you up and
running what are you queuing up for
what's in
here CL nobin I in
here my lady want to
dance oh
God I'm broken it get out of here
quick blow up Are you full
of oh
no lot of lot of repeated gags happening
here last last Town it might be time to
jump in the
workshop up here oh that helicopter
where's the helicopter go it's some I
should bring you on a helicopter ride my
love oh a
damn let's go to the
D every video game level has a
dam
I
bye he was a nice man wasn't he
honey oh [__]
uhoh I'm want to get this silly lady off
of me oh man you can just jump across
the walls look at this can I wall ride
as well
here can I wall ride with this lady on
me I want to get rid of her anyway she's
annoying me oh you're kidding me oh
hello what are
you can I have
you start a race [__] yeah you can race
God they've added so much this video
game they're really giving back to the
community all right let's
go
go actual video game part of this video
game oh I totally cut a wall R there
couldn't
i
y
yeah where's the next
one where's the next
one what where's the
next I
blind jump over with my sweet wall
running
skills oh there it is oh you kidding me
I got to go up there
Jesus
right
ah running is
hard there we go nailed
it oh that's why the up arrow is there
only for this Race
part I'm going to set a new faster
lap
Jesus Christ
ah nailed
it run oh you can run straight up walls
you can run straight up
walls yep sure that seems
legit get off this wall too Titanfall
didn't even have
that watch and
respawn what's
done oh it's going to bring me back to
the
dam favorite part of the level
this guy
again Sweet take that everyone snil off
you
suck great now I've got this dude on me
instead does that mean I didn't lick the
thing that was in the Mutant Ninja
Turtles area does that mean that was a
different
uh no maybe that was a Col
God damn
it let's go this
way Alor
City I go in here you're going to shoot
me out sure let's see what's there is
that the first
level oh this place again nope
Le I got rid of the dude off my back
hopefully
anyway all right I'm going to get myself
a laptop because I forgot to set it up
silly me get some uh get some chat going
if you all know any Easter eggs on this
bad boy please let me know uh we're
going to go to an ad break in the
meantime so I'm going to sit here with
my boys in slow motion until then
what's going on
dudes I got the chat open you all have
any you inside information on this bad
boy let me know just not going my dudes
just
chilling I'm some
fun Justin hey Wald is me in the chat
apparently who
knew all right let's do this how you
doing
folks
another Oh I thought that might be
another sewer I got all
excited let's go into the
mountains
oh never known go if you're finding an
Easter drag or finding a hidden area or
just wandering into a part on the map
they never finished oh this would be the
former uh
okay sort of
alien I don't even is this the UFO from
the first level is that what this is can
I go up this
way go Dam
it
lick the lights will not do
anything that reckon some sort of
Hitchhiker's Guide
reference walk up that ladder using my
sweet goat
skills come on get off the fre bringing
ladder oh you're the worst goat
ever yep sure that
works by the way I hate you all give me
this
axe on my
axe oh
God nailed it and out of here great form
all
right where's the easiest place to hop
on that Chopper is it over
here oh I'm going to lick that Chopper
so
hard wait for the
chopper come on over
here
jerk you got a pretty good uh launch
into the skate park here
actually here we go here we
go oh
no look at you yes
yes all of my dreams have come
true oh
[__] I'm still good I'm still
good don't get don't get cut off stay on
it stay on it stay on it you stupid
yep St on it oh there's a [__] party
on up here you going to drop me
off disconnect my tongue disengage the
tongue yes it's my birthday
party
this is the dumbest
[__] yep
sure hey what's
up re
bar I want to go I want to be the
front
is that [__] dead
mouse
what oh this game is just keeps getting
weirder and
weirder
wow Hey look it's me and my boy dead
mouse and we're
just
yay
a
this is a bit
mental all
right I'm going lick dead
M licking dead mouse but he's so good he
doesn't fall
over oh you can totally kill that mes
sorry that
mes now all of you
die you don't even need him to play
music he's playing on sound so fine
Jesus Christ what
happens fireworks uhoh
uhoh Goat
Simulator
what get out of here Dead
Goat all
right oh just me think you're just you
think you're done just deliver something
new I'm Dum all right have any dead M
Powers hey what's up don't worry it's me
dead
M
yep Dead Man 5 it's me dead man
5 come with me to my concert
dude hey lady hey lady hey lady here
here
lady hey lady where'd you go there you
go I want to see dead go try and uh walk
up a
ladder it's in here put in hotel you
can't come I'm going on my own hello I'm
dead M 5 I believe you have a room for
me I'll bring you to my room
now love how immediately everybody
freaks out
now bring me to my
room it's a shitty
hotel come with
me oh
elevator
oh we're going back up to the
party hey it's me I'm
back yeah you're all back dancing eh
sorry about
that yeah get off my this is my
party get off my dce floor you [__]
my party my
party
no I be screaming oh you think you're
okay on the edge yeah
nope God damn it stop dancing
here Love dead man fight so much that
they can't stop dancing I must kill them
all I'm going to go back in the head
helicopter when it comes back where's it
gone the
chopper where's dead mare 5's
Chopper it's over there it's over
there get off my
stage get off my
stage there you go get
off com the
chopper head to the
chopper
oh God Dam it one more [__] get
up
no oh got
away
I got a Firework by
accident bye everybody enjoy the
party enjoy the
party what else is up
here go to the secret
Island press
r
oh my
God oh my
God I can just make a party anywhere I
want how did I get the
freaking how did I get the manual to
work there was the first time I got it
to
work everyone's partying look they all
love it hey you hey guys
party
yeah
hey you sad gu on the on the on the
bridge party yeah I'll punch you great
hey truck hey truck
party oh bring me to a party
okay apparently this is on flash sale or
was it
on not
surprised I wonder if dead man I've made
this song especially for goatsy emulator
I think I broke
something people people over here need
to learn how to
dance hey what's
up
party
yeah I'm not falling for that one
again I still have not to go on this
roller coaster actually where's the uh
oh yeah I'm manualing there's manual
look at that I'm manualing Tony
HW just like Tony Hawk I'm going to use
the slow-mo Chief to gain this
system this sick manual Rodney Mullen
ain't got [__] on
me oh face
PL I do a regular
Manuel oh he's on the
front all right let's do
it where is the entrance to the roller
coaster is you turnning that music
off this I can't tell oh hello
hello I take this
elevator well the goat simulator's got a
lot of
elevators or
lifts
head CH you're right that nice taking
over video
games in sand
shapes get up get up don't [__] fall
on me better to lick that thing lick it
oh you stupid dead
mou all right let's try that
again yep
sure hey
lady hey lady you don't want to come
over here some [__] up shit's
happening yeah not
surprised I have a similar
reaction okay I clipped through the I
clipped through the Earth fine now you
drown want that elevator to come back
down come on give me our go I'll do
better this time I swear where' that
lady
go all right while I'm waiting for that
I'm going to have a go in a sweet
slide
we maybe I should go over here what's
over
here
nothing what's that over there is that a
goat in the
distance sort of Goat
Island want way to find
out look at this [__]
nonsense
go I'm blocking it so you can't see
it
yeah de M
five wonder if that yeah I got to look
up if dead M actually wrote this music
especially for this is that an invisible
wall son of a [__] video game no way is
this an invisible
wall got put it's a [__] invisible
wall let push me
back what is there like a special angle
I got to take to hit this thing
I love how it's actually just two trees
I really thought it looked like a
goat that is deeply
frustrating go back to the city I
guess
wow oh yeah totally forgot about this
Workshop let's do it see what we
got dead M was good manualing was good
wall riding was
good but you just know the workshop's
got some good [__] here Flying
Goat nin is kind of cat
you if you're a Ninja
Goat you're a ninja all
right so Ninja
Goat Ninja Goat looks a little bit
shitty
that we go
by we do is that Jake wow Jake from
Adventure Time that's pretty
good what's this
football
telekinesis stranded cloning goat
feeling
alone postal what Midtown Madness postal
cheat this is a tribute to my favorite
childood games for those unaware the
postal cheat in mid their Madness lets
you fire mailbox with your
horn all right
sold get that one downloading what else
we got here a
Maria oh you're kidding me it plays a
Maria when you go in slowmo it's just
like playing
Hitman it's like the last level of H
Hitman blood Money Right wow that's
great uh here we have a
doge such mod wow that's pretty
good hell for
goats lag people melons swinger and
jumping Abu ghost visit the Temple of
Abu symbol as a ghost
sure pretty
good
else we
got chameleon
goat Chang your goat in game that's
pretty good popcorn the more I learn the
more I will add to this map I'm also
working on other Maps sounds good Flappy
goat full screen great a mod for the
already existing Flappy goat oh my God
baby goat oh that's terrifying that's
terrifying
subscribe
those you [__] 0%
me you do that to
me all right in L of those downloading
come on download now be downloaded
now my
mods no I do not want to make m
maybe they are actually downloaded from
this is being
weird no not yet all right all right
going have one more Go goat City Bay
goatville that was the original one
right Lappy goat fat goat I like the CH
fat goat I'm going to go fat
goat why that baby goat more than
anything else although I'll be honest
this F go is pretty
good is that a go I get this fat goat
wall
ride wall
run oh
[__] yep nailed
it
nice oh this guy's
fast look at this
goat speedboat
goat bring me to an island maybe this
guy brings me to the secret
Island secondary I was worried that
maybe
by by having him murdered I stopped
myself from getting here but don't fall
off don't fall off you stupid [__]
goat is that the secret Island
there all right restart you can do that
again it's very important I see that
secret Goat
Island bring me to the
island so this swimming pool is okay oh
this fast goat is so fat fat goat is so
f i just drinking by the
pool
healthy nailed
it get this sick wall
ride right all right I'm jumping on this
and immediate imately licking
it immediate leg jump
leg I'm licking the boat there nothing
that can kick me off that science
work I'm looking the [__] out of this
boat bring me to the paradise bring me
to the secret
Island go I couldn't get out of here by
my own
means what's out here on this secret
Island there has to be something
here hey what's going
on bring me out here for no
reason Jesus Christ what's going
on bat go is having trouble
here quick
sand headbo armchair all I see is this
boat I think it's an armchair but
okay that is there nothing out
here
I know it's a
trap am I stuck here now is this like
lost give me that thing let me lick that
thing is that thing lick it Li
it ooh I tried some
shrooms what could go
wrong am I a [__] raccoon
now what the what I'm going to eat some
more
mushrooms right
okay these mushrooms are delicious I
better keep eating
them sweet delicious mushrooms
perhaps this has gone a bit weird cuz
because I'm not wearing I'm
I'm I'm not using the actual uh original
goat skin
but give me this
mushroom let eat all the
mushrooms oh my other ear is big
now we can keep doing this we can keep
licking these delicious mushrooms
think you have to knock them over before
you eat
them can't tell if it's getting weirder
or not it's already so
weird eat the mushroom
I don't know what to tell you
folks bet is probably going to freak out
a bunch of those people oh negated it
damn
it oh well all right let me see if this
God damn
it let me see if this these mods
downloaded
oh apparently I'm supposed to hit R you
kidding me God damn it I have to go back
and do that
again no you're going to be jerks all
right one more time I'm going to go back
to
goatville I'm not I'm going to be a
regular ass
goat I'm going to go over and eat those
rooms and press R and see what happens
no not goatville godam
it out of here I want to go to my
Seaside seaside
resort
come with
me
yes my set is offline on Steam actually
maybe that's what it
is
wait hopefully they're downloading
now go
goat nope here we
go here we go
oh that other that our goat was so much
faster than this
one going keep keep
Goen go
this here we
go run goat
man get that sweet first person
goat
go it's mushroom time
baby keep forgetting that pressing or
usually does the
uh secret move oh you jerk
game God damn
it whoa what is he
doing no jump over the car don't
no
why not licking that boat I was pretty
sure I was licking that
boats
are shouting at me now those people
talk [__]
[__]
[__] all right if I don't get it done
this time we're
done I just need to see what happens I
bet nothing will happen to in the
end see what happens what the [__] keep
finding other
things okay there is multiplayer and
goat CA
confirmed God damn
it it
work do
it I heard go m
hang your tongue out like an idiot some
kind of animal okay here we go what I
did last time has got to hide in between
these
bits yeah there hopefully that will
hopefully that'll
stick I'm
okay got to lick and kind of sit in that
little pocket as
well
Back to the Island the
island nail
it
here
got
weirder beting
these oh my tongue's gotten
weird
pressing or does
nothing worth a
shot I do look absolutely gorgeous
though go simulator
everybody